infrastructure it's our roads bridges
dams levees airports power grids
basically anything that can be destroyed
in an action movie
[Applause]
we if an alien species judged
humanity by our most popular movies
they'd think we were furious with
asphalt all the time the problem is
though when our infrastructure is not
being destroyed by robots and or saved
by Bruce Willis we tend to find it a bit
boring as you know infrastructure is not
a sexy or glamorous topic as much as I'd
like to think otherwise infrastructure
is not sexy infrastructure is not very
sexy
yes infrastructure like those men we
just heard from is important but not
sexy although to be fair that may just
be because Hollywood promotes
unrealistic standards of infrastructure
beauty that's not what a real Road looks
like real roads had curves so most most
people think infrastructure for I think
it's boring but but is it because I'd
argue that it's actually pretty
fascinating and I know that in saying
that I've basically become the rad youth
counselor trying to convince you that
Jesus was the Taylor Swift of his time
revelations is a breakup song to the
Romans guys who want another Mountain
Dew catch so let's talk about
infrastructure tonight and let's begin
with dams because dams are amazing
they're the most powerful device we have
for holding back liquid aside from the
idea of using a porta potti oh wait I'll
just wait forever
I cannot go in there America used to
love dams Grand Coulee Dam in Washington
State
biggest concrete structure Boulder Dam
stands today a modern Colossus the walls
of the new dam tower into the sky like
mighty modern pyramid yes and we built
those dams with ingenuity and brawn and
of course piles and piles of dead Irish
that of course we did they're good
workers and their corpses make a solid
foundation material that's an
architectural fact but these days
America's wants great dam system is in a
state of serious disrepair the average
age of the country's 84,000 dams is 52
years and many of them have problems
that stem from when they were first
built yes much like most Botox
recipients and competitive cloggers the
average Dam is 52 years old and probably
has something deeply broken inside of it
you would think a statistic like that
would terrify people into action but
amazingly many states are paying
virtually no attention to their dam
problems in 2007 the last year for which
statistics are available Texas had just
seven inspectors responsible for seventy
four hundred dams that's over 1,050 dams
per inspector the state was only able to
look at 239 dams Alabama doesn't even
have an Inspection Agency to monitor its
2,000 plus dams zero inspectors that
means that the state of Alabama has
exactly the same number of damaged
Spector's as the banned Alabama and it's
not just dams we're currently doing a
terrible job of maintaining all of our
infrastructure the nation's
infrastructure and bridges roads and
pipelines is sorely in need of
renovation collectively they get nothing
more than a d+ a d+ think about that
America got the same grade that a 10th
grade teacher gives a nightmare kid so
she doesn't have to deal with him for
another year
no no London we're not calculating the
surface area of our penises just give
him a d+ and say has family troubles I
cannot even deal with that again
and look to be fair that deep last grade
came from the American Society of Civil
Engineers who would clearly benefit from
more infrastructure spending so it's a
bit like having the state of our
nation's tennis ball assessed by the
American Society of golden retrievers
they're dangerously underthrown this
must change we've been such good dogs
such good dogs but other studies have
also found our infrastructure is lacking
the World Economic Forum ranks America's
16th in the world and we need to be
better because when infrastructure fails
bad things happen like last year when a
pipe burst and flooded the campus of
UCLA a water main break in West Los
Angeles turned the UCLA campus into a
river students walked through ankle-deep
water or in some cases tried to have fun
with the situation I've been chilling
here for 20 minutes trying to get the
best view yeah I actually just came from
the gym it's like I've never seen so
much water except for like lakes I got
[Applause]
it's not just incredibly expensive
it can also be lethal from the big stuff
like bridge collapses and dam failures
to the little stuff like potholes gone
at 53 years old al Li slammed his bike
into a pothole riding along Grizzly Peak
Boulevard in Oakland his wife Nancy says
a car then hit him head-on roads need to
be paved that's why we have
infrastructure that's why we pay our
taxes that's horrifying but the problem
is we only ever seem to talk about
infrastructure when something tragic
like that happens and the scale of this
problem is scary as the former Secretary
of Transportation points out according
to the government there's 70,000 bridges
that hadn't been deemed structurally
deficient yeah what does that mean it
means that their bridges that need to be
really either replaced or repaired in a
very dramatic way
they're dangerous I don't want to say
they're unsafe but they're dangerous
hold on when we're at a point where the
Secretary of Transportation is
struggling to decide between using the
word unsafe and the word dangerous we
might have a problem worth fixing and if
you want a glimpse into how close to
catastrophe we occasionally are take
this story from Philadelphia in 2008 two
contractors from the Pennsylvania
Department of Transportation stopped to
get a sausage sandwich and park their
cars under this bridge
unfortunately they wanted that sausage
sandwich because they saw one of these
piers with an eight-foot gash in it
about five inches wide and if they had
mortar the sausage sandwich there's a
strong likelihood that bridge would have
collapsed so there might have been a
disaster if those Philly contractors
hadn't wanted to stop for a sausage
sandwich which means we were fine we
were always going to be fine
but but but the scary thing is the scary
thing is what if the next crack pillow
in Philadelphia is next to a vegan
smoothie stand that bridge is going down
and people are going to die and it's not
just Philadelphia look at Pittsburgh the
city of bridges and its solution to one
that was dangerously deteriorating one
of these arch bridges actually has a
structure built under it to catch
falling deck see that structure
underneath it they actually built that
to catch in in the falling concrete so
wouldn't hurt traffic underneath it they
built a bridge under the bridge that is
a college sophomore approach to
structural engineering where the trash
was overflowing so I just started
putting it in the microwave problem
solved
I'm a legend and there are dangerous
bridges everywhere here in New York the
Tappan Zee Bridge is so notoriously
shaky one government official in charge
of fixing it cause it's a hold your
breath bridge and the only time we
should ever talk about hold your breath
bridges would be if for some reason beau
bridges were into auto-erotic
asphyxiation and you were trying to
remember which one he was is either
normal bridges or is he the hold your
breath bridges
it's important that I know this the
facts about the Tappan Zee Bridge are
frightening enough and yet the History
Channel felt the need to produce a
terrifyingly cgi filled account of the
worst case scenario some of the Tappan
Zee sound ations
are at risk and this is what could
happen if they eventually gave way
okay one one that's very frightening but
two why did the director assume we'd all
had such a strong emotional attachment
to the coffee cup King Bridge just
collapsed at this point we aren't just
flirting with disaster we're rounding
third base and asking if disaster has
any condoms and the crazy thing is ask
any politician from either side and
they'll tell you that infrastructure is
incredibly important everyone agrees on
this in fact at a recent hearing both
business and labor in the form of the US
Chamber of Commerce and the afl-cio
turned out to support infrastructure
spending and even they know how rare
that is if business and labor can come
before you United on this issue and we
are united on this issue despite our
sharp disagreements on a variety of
other matters I think that should tell
everybody something and tell them very
loudly he's right the last time business
and labor agreed on an issue it was the
issue of how dead should Jimmy Hoffa be
they both agreed pretty dead hey here's
how obvious our need is just two days
ago even a total idiot agreed we have to
rebuild our infrastructure crumbling
everything's crumbling and we're
rebuilding China okay now what's the
labor whatever the he was talking about
regarding rebuilding China that
upside-down piece of candy corn in a wig
made of use medical gauze is right we do
have to rebuild our infrastructure so
with consensus like this how are things
so bad well one of the problems is just
fixing things is not politically
appealing because when you build
something new you get to do this
[Applause]
[Music]
there is nothing politicians like more
than using oversized scissors to cut
through ribbons but you don't get to cut
a ribbon after routine repairs
infrastructure is like Legos building is
fun destroying is fun but a Lego
maintenance set would be the most boring
toy in the world it comes built
and then you maintain it and if you do
it right nothing happens and eventually
you die have fun son perhaps the best
symbol for our neglected infrastructure
is the US Highway Trust Fund it is the
single largest source of infrastructure
funding in this country and guess what's
about to happen to it there's a May 31st
deadline this year the Highway Trust
Fund goes bankrupt unless Congress acts
yeah the fund is about to run out of
money and unlike most broke trust fund
recipients our highway system can't just
get a job at its daddy's Law Firm really
Declan what case are you working on and
does it contain 24 Miller lights I hate
you Declan the reason the fund is nearly
insolvent is that it's primarily funded
by the federal gas tax and there's just
one hitch with that the Highway Trust
Fund gets revenue from an eighteen point
four cent per gallon gas tax but the tax
has not increased to keep up with
inflation since 1993 and the fact that
it hasn't increased means that in real
terms the gas tax has gone down 39%
since 1993 much like Koosh ball sales or
respect for Bill Cosby
I'd like to think it was more than that
but sadly I don't think it is actually
you would think that Congress would fix
this shortfall but we haven't had
long-term transportation legislation for
over a decade
in fact since 2003 it's barely passed
two partial authorizations and 23
short-term extensions one of which in
July 2005 was for just two days two days
that entire extension lasted half a
sting orgasm that's not enough so so you
might think why doesn't Washington just
raise the gas tax and fund the fund well
because that would be incredibly
unpopular listen to what happened when
c-span had a call in and asked people
whether or not the gas tax should be
raised
I don't know that another gas tax is
gonna help us out okay no they shouldn't
raise the gas gauge okay the last thing
we need is new taxes okay if gas prices
go back up we'll be stuck with the super
high prices okay what I want to say is
no war on coal war on gasoline war on
diesel I agree with all of the other
previous callers okay okay that calling
lasted for nearly an hour and they did
not receive a single call in favor of
the gas tax you would think they'd at
least have been prank calls by Mikey in
the Badger dc's number one morning zoo
crew hi I just like to say we should
definitely raise the gas tax
you've been badgered
[Applause]
[Music]
face in the face of that kinda
overwhelming lack of public support it
is hardly surprising that the White
House is not too keen on it either
the administration has not put forward
and does not plan to put forward a
proposal to increase the gas tax okay so
it seems raising the gas tax is unlikely
which is fine as long as you have
another concrete way to raise that money
so what is the White House's plan this
administration has put forward an idea
by essentially you know closing a
loophole that allows corporations to
benefit from stashing some of their
profits overseas okay raise funds by
closing corporate loopholes I think we
all know that is guaranteed to work
the only obstacle would be and I know
that this is highly unlikely if there
were another corporate loophole
somewhere else in the tax code oh oh and
there is one other obstacle when the
president floated this plan by John
Boehner a year ago he swatted it aside
perhaps because Boehner favors his own
plan which he's been talking up for the
past two years I'm committed to working
a defined a funding source so that we
can begin to repair America's aging
infrastructure The Hunt has been
underway for the last year and a half to
find out funding source which I could
report to you we found it but we haven't
we've got to find a way to deal with
America's a crumbling infrastructure and
we do need to do it in a long-term
program that that is in fact funded two
years and nothing that is but an oddly
laid back way to tackle a potentially
catastrophic problem because if a giant
lizard we're attacking our roads and
bridges you wouldn't spend two years
saying yes I am committed to preventing
marauding lizards destroying our city
but we need to do it in a long-term
program that is in fact funded I refuse
to believe that after all this time
Boehner does not have some sort of plan
we actually emailed his office earlier
this week and asked what is Speaker
Boehner's proposal to raise revenue for
the US Highway Trust Fund we didn't hear
back
so we emailed someone else in the office
still nothing so we
call to the office still nothing at this
point we were getting desperate so we
sent in this tweet asking mr. speaker
how specifically will you raise revenue
for the US Highway Trust Fund hashtag
happy birthday Justin Bieber just to
make sure that he would see it for
definite still nothing then we found out
that he's on vine for some reason
because apparently he's 14 in 2013 so we
sent him this mr. speaker how
specifically would you raise revenue for
the US Highway Trust Fund is that six
seconds it feels like I'd be a lot
longer nothing he still didn't get back
to us look the lack of political urgency
in tackling this problem is insane and
you cannot tell me that you are not
interested in this because every summer
people flock to see our infrastructure
threatened by terrorists or aliens but
we should care just as much when it's
under threats from the inevitable
passage of time the problem is no one
has made a blockbuster movie about the
importance of routine maintenance and
repair or they hadn't until now we're a
few feet of concrete can mean the
difference between life and death where
everything you love can be taken from
you in the blink of an eye a few brave
souls are willing to risk everything to
make nothing happen it's time for your
biennial bridge inspection I've got
Thursday afternoon or Friday anytime
before 3:00 this summer get ready for
infrastructure brace yourself for 98
heart-pounding minutes of incremental
maintenance I'm not showing any cracking
note the lamination dose falls on the
concrete deck that you got mild
corrosion on feet you're gonna have to
keep an eye on that thank you sir
don't get cocky the New York Times calls
infrastructure necessary and something I
never thought about but yeah sure
Jesus Scott Bobby behind you sickness
this thing is gonna blow
fifteen or twenty years which is farts
so important that we caught it early
[Music]
in this line of work one mistake could
be catastrophic it's loose boss bolt is
loose well then tighten it god dammit I
don't know which one
okay listen to me listen to me listen
lefty-loosey righty-tighty
[Applause]
[Music]
talk to me what's going on
it's good
[Applause]
holy stone says nothing happens and
that's probably for the best
I came here to chew bubblegum and
inspect bridges
you want to see terrible puns about
engineering you don't fully understand
looks like somebody needs to get their
ducks in a row you want to see 20 minute
monologues on the structural integrity
of girders I'm ordering uniaxial test to
the slab transverse to the deck
corrugations with additional
reinforcement and tension tests of the
support fastener connections between the
deck and the girders routine
maintenance that you can handle they use
PVC piping when they should have used
see PVC piping
god help us you want to see
infrastructure
featuring an all-star cast plus two-time
Academy Award nominee Edward Norton
sorry three-time Academy Award nominee
Edward Norton
and introducing as the chief steve
buscemi I'm the best damn inspector in
the business and I'm here to inspect us
dam infrastructure if anything exciting
happens we've done it wrong sausage
sandwich of course
you